well the EPA today has been given some
Authority but frankly the best way to
address the issue of climate change is
not through the regulatory process it's
through the legislative process unless
Congress is the one that really has to
act they have to set the standard they
have to set out the cap-and-trade
program as they did in the clean air act
amendments of 1990 because when Congress
acts that's the law and you don't get
hauled into court when EPA acts every
time it does anything with a regulation
it gets into court and if we're serious
about solving a problem we put it off
another 10 15 years because that's how
long it takes to work its way through
the courts on these very high-profile
very important decisions